What are you interested in in science?
Well, I like genetics.
My high school teacher actually started my interest in genetics...
...but I still have a lot to learn about the field.
Well, I started my own career in genetics...
...and then I decided that the brain was where all the action was...
...so I became a neurogeneticist.
Still to this day, study genes that control brain, behavior, activity...
...and especially Alzheimer's disease.
So what would you say your motivation is?
I think after you live your whole life...
...and you develop all these memories and personality and who you are,...
...it's not fair that a disease comes and robs exactly that from you.
And robs it from everyone who loves you and knows you.
So I'm motivated by the need to just eradicate this disease from the planet.
What is the best advice that anyone has ever given you?
Don't be afraid to think wildly...
...and speculate wildly in the privacy and silence of your own brain...
...'cause you can then decide what you're going to say out to others.
So, allow yourself to make free associations...
...'cause that's where some of the best ideas come from.
The second part of that is that when you go into the lab,...
...if you wanna do good science,...
...your only job is to disprove what you think.
My original mentor at Harvard told me,...
..."Date your hypothesis, never marry it."
Always be open to revising what you think.